unser roth mit farid bang und das ist
genauer die ellerstraße in düsseldorf
hinterm hauptbahnhof und da hat der
stadt gefunden dass nrw youtuber treffen
mit abschließendem babbel tee und das
hat er nicht bekommen da reden wir unter
anderem drüber und wir sind bei seinem
lieblings friseur der diese phänomenale
frisur von dem hinkriegt wir sprechen
über seinen lieblings restaurant sind
bei seinem lieblings gemüsehändler und
ihr werdet es nicht glauben was seinen
hervorragend ausgestatteten
genitalbereich ähnlich sieht seid also
gespannt auf diese kleine tour durchs
viertel vom fahrrad weg bis dann bleibt
also partie ist die ellerstraße hinterm
hauptbahnhof in düsseldorf
und was mir sofort aufgefallen ist
restaurant café imbiss bäckerei
restaurant man kann ja überall essen auf
jeden fall
und die trägt sich nicht gegenseitig auf
die füße die sind alle freunde und das
ist 12 cellisten köln auf der
kreuzstraße also und das ganze ist quasi
in klein marokko klammer rocco das heißt
du kannst alles cousins und onkels
theoretisch ja
los gehts wirklich okay dann würden wir
mal bei uns nur ein weg ja alles gut
silber der stress kein schritt wollen
wir die lektionen der markt denn er
macht ständig neues album kommt jetzt
hier ich weiß dass der letzte tag dann
sprechen dass wir geben den rest dafür
bin ich okay verwandtschaftsgrad das ist
onkel ali hat jetzt von allen welche von
düsseldorf
der onkel von einem freund wäre jetzt
der falsche begriff sowie halt einer von
der älteren garde und für uns auch den
onkel des regung als in neapel sagt man
glaube ich der partei
ja so könnte man auch in düsseldorf ist
das glaub ich schaue die richtige für
ihn okay so hilft die bahnhof-apotheke
okay was bekommt man da mit gefälschten
rezepten und ja grad vielleicht jetzt da
hinten ist das berüchtigte wandern ja
okay das ist ja ein bisschen mode okay
das ist wenn man nach düsseldorf reisen
mit
damit gewann ganz genau welche nummer 1
hits do 23 22 okay wir uns zwar noch
jung und knackig die chance ansprechen
wenn du wenn in so etablissements aber
du wirst jetzt natürlich vor einer
kamera sage da reden wir nicht drüber
aufregen wenn ich treffe jedoch geheim
wir wissen natürlich dass wir nicht
zumindest ehrlich als zu sagen nee ich
habe damit nichts zu tun
ich habe so was noch nie auf ihr sucht
ich bin der liebste mensch
jedermann hat gerade sagen kann ach da
sozusagen
ich hoffe nicht enttäuscht mich nicht
links von uns ist der hauptbahnhof das
riesending wo sie den turm hoch gebaut
haben und davon ist der hauptbahnhof und
das gibt es am hauptbahnhof hier am
hauptbahnhof youtuber treffen gibt's da
ich hatte mir letztlich ein riesen
youtuber treffen mit hunderten youtube
am hauptbahnhof herrlich haben aber
richtig wie wir die luft in so einem
youtuber triphop man kommt zusammen und
dann fotografiert was ich mag videos
gibt autogramme macht shoutout kanäle
und dann irgendwann trinkbar petit das
wichtig dass man muss alle fliegen war
dort eine riesenschlange beim habel
das habe ich gesehen ich bin dann
angefangen haben genau gemacht da war so
ein bubble tea und so eine riesige
schlange
es war der tag das ist irgendwie das
youtuber trendgetränk das ist ja sowieso
achten kommen aber davon ist das
polizeipräsidium ideal da hab ich schon
die eine oder andere nacht verbracht da
bist du da jetzt unter deinen freunden
und die sag mal in dem umkreis ein
vorbild
was sie wirklich merken ja der hat recht
ich denke schon auch wenn ich jünger bin
ich war immer schon einer der jüngsten
in meinem freundeskreis aber ich will
immer schon zu den weiteren sagen wir es
mal so wir den anderen immer etwas
mitgeben kann weil ich auch immer sehr
sehr weit vor arbeite und mir sehr oft
gesagt wird dass ich für mein alter sehr
weit bin ja also guckt euch nicht ab was
die ganzen rap kollegen euch erzählen
und wenn die im interview kippen oder so
nicht scheiße
sie sind uncool ja noch keine kohle in
der tasche ich mag es nicht wenn jüngere
leute von mir zigaretten rauchen also
auch die junge leute die ich kenne
ich habe schon öfters die jüngeren
ohrfeige deswegen gegeben oder soja ich
würde sowas garnicht dass oder werden
die dann gerade noch oder dann würde
zumindest nicht vor mir auf und dann
es geht hier nicht darum zu zeigen ich
bin jetzt der große starke wird in dem
moment geht es darum ihn zu demütigen
für diese dummheit jeder da macht als
sein großer bruder also dass ich mich
schon sehr häufig vorgekommen oder wenn
jemand alkohol trinken so das ist jetzt
selber mit drogen alkohol zieht gar
nichts ich will ins pro tag leben hier
ein obstladen superangebot was einmal
hier
kürbisse ja wirklich auch sagen
kürbisse enorm in form wie es die form
vom kürbis als würdest du sagen ich
würde sagen würde oder ich kann ja mal
meine jeans haus ziehen und dann spielt
langsam vorstellen was jetzt im
interview schock thematisiert oder warum
fragen lotto richtig also von obst
kommen wir gehen hier kommt man sieht so
hier
wie geht man diese versorgen händen so
total kurz und nach vorne so 3 mm das
ist sie halt hiervon die seiten immer
mit null millimeter und das wird mit
ihrer geschnitten und die vorsorge vorne
und oben
ein bisschen mit schere und kultur und
mit messer wie oft muss er dann hier
einmal die woche hatte war einmal eine
woche reicht bei besonderen anlässen
zweimal aber in der regel einmal okay da
sind besondere anlässe
klicks um 14
die haare schneiden ich habe das auch so
ein unterschied haben also wenn man in
die ellerstraße gegen alles mal
ausprobieren alles ausprobieren auf
jeden fall mit dem café casablanca hier
dass man damals schön arbeit hier nicht
willkommen hier das muss mal kurz wer
durch schenken so stellt man sich das da
guckt man
fußball ja okay da werden karten
gespielt nicht um geld sondern hier man
spielt um ein getränk okay außer nach 12
uhr da gelten andere regeln wird nach 24
uhr
[Gelächter]
und ja wir gucken fußball hier wird
shisha geraucht jetzt eigentlich etwas
haben heute donnerstag donnerstag ging
später wird es hier auch mal richtig
jetzt ist der mann der die supermacht
und es geht hier auf jeden fall ab und
der grünen sagt nein hier werden keine
drogen konsumiert sondern nur schicker
wir sind ja schon gefällt dir
ich habe mein lieblings dj von
deutschland von amerika österreich
schweizer sportler des mars jupiter
straße milchstraße heller straße einer
straße landstraße über die beiden das
auf die beiden wollen öffentlich in die
mitte von ihnen stellten vorgemacht
komm doch mal ein foto hat die kamera
mit küsschen
war mein vertrauen in wirklichkeit steht
er doch gar nicht auf so einen macho
gotti enttäuscht dass die ganze nation
verwirrung in frauenhand
das wird eine hübsche frauen die wollen
richtige männer haben und nicht die
frauen fordern
ist nicht so - und muss trainieren und
auch die männlichkeit nach testbeginn
hier mal rein ich dass das bremer tor
neben ich weiß es nicht aber ich glaube
generell in deutschland ist
gibt es in frankfurt
so das war's eigentlich von ehlers
straße sowie um die rimc facetten dass
nach dem fisch haben wir das nun
fischhandel gibt auch immer weniger ja
die gibt es hier noch
von ihrer mutter und das sind kleine
kinder kleine töchter und söhne
wie viel hat keine von dem ich als ok
sehr schön
wie viele freundinnen asse ich bin
glücklich und deswegen sage ich hier
noch freundinnen keine wirklich
glücklich ist es ist super ich sag's der
typische aussage der notorischen
fremdgänger nein ehrlich es schon 20
jahre schön wollt mich glücklich die
richtige gefunden ist kann jedem nur
wenn sie den richtigen will auch
gefunden
es kann jeden fall wünschen ja klar
also leute da draußen macht es wieder
christoph versucht durch eine
vernünftige frau zeigt gesunde kinder
und liebt das leben absolut und hat was
vom leben und ja dort läuft das hier so
sieht's aus okay das war's von der
ellerstraße in düsseldorf
heimat kann meine heimat und ich hoffe
bald auch eure heimat kommt vorbei kauft
obst gemüse geht hier essen geht zum
friseur und er ist sensationell
also bis zum nächsten mal